today we're talking about no cost
learning 10 it predictions and the
December trust update I'm Alicia and
welcome to the very last this week in
cloud of 2022 where we serve you the
lowest latency news
for the season of giving we've wrapped
up some of our most popular training and
certification opportunities and made
them available at no cost this December
we're aiming to offer something for
everyone whether you're just getting
started with cloud or knee deep in
preparing for a professional
certification exam
start with the fundamentals to gain a
deeper understanding of cloud whether
you're in a business or technical role
or jump into a Hot Topic like
sustainability and learn about Google's
commitment to a clean cloud and how to
use sustainability tools see all the
details on the blog
we love helping organizations imagine
what's possible and build the technology
that converts opportunities into reality
to do this we think it's important to
look towards the future so we can help
developers and businesses learn grow and
build the world's most powerful systems
and immersive experiences with 2022
winding down we're highlighting our
Cloud technology predictions one by one
to share where we're headed and help you
prepare for the years ahead
every day at teams across Google Cloud
come together to help address complex
and pressing compliance risk and privacy
requirements in order to enable
customers to accelerate their digital
transformation and innovate faster
we've got another installment from the
cyber security action team that rounds
up our top trust and compliance related
efforts from the last few months of 2022
and you can see them all on the blog
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link any thoughts or ideas leave
us a comment or tweet us we'll see you
next year in the cloud